hey how's it going welcome to Vlog
University how you guys doing did I ask
you how I I did I did I definitely
did so the last episode of Vlog
University I had you guys get really
crazy go to a grocery store and dance
and I didn't actually think that any of
you would really do
itake it's time for a grocery dancing
Montage you ready to go dance for
Justine
so it wouldn't be fair if I made you
guys go to a grocery store and dance and
I didn't participate as well so H yep
check out the sweet sweet dance
moves I am never going to be all a
grocery store ever
again
Ladi is your homework so the other day
on YouTube I did a live show and during
the live show I asked you guys for a
vlog University assignment so this
homework assignment is being brought to
you by it's epic Joe pretend you have
your own cooking show and make a wacky
dish with hilarious commentary that is
your homework assignment for the next
episode of Vlog University so how this
works is you guys go out make a video
add that is a video response to this
video and come back here to see the next
episode and see if your video made it
into the next episode how many times did
I say episode I'm sure there's probably
a lot so maybe hopefully I can edit a
few of those out that's it for Vlog
University if you want to see my full
dance in the grocery store feel free to
click here uh hopefully there's an
annotation there if not then I just look
like I'm pointing at nothing and don't
forget to subscribe so you can see when
I post more videos here on YouTube thank
you guys for always participating in
Vlog University this is one of my
favorite shows and it couldn't actually
be made without you guys so I will see
you in the next episode and don't get
kicked out of any grocery stores
cuz where else you going to get some
food at don't know don't know
bye